before you start telling them you look
like chris matthews or bill o'reilly
let's first let the world know who's on
here today
former 15-year kgb member i think 1973
to 1988
uh is here with us jack barsky jack and
i had a
zoom interview a couple months ago which
was very entertaining to say the least i
think we had a good time together
uh uh and
i hear the background whoever's got it
on someone's got it on
jack grabbed the mic no but somebody has
the audio on that's playing is that you
no just
okay what's him no tyler i don't know
just put the mic in front of you yeah
so uh but it's uh good to have you on uh
we talked last time about uh yuri
besnemof uh uh uh uh besmanov we talked
about the fact that he talked about the
four stages demoralization
destabilization
stage three is crisis normalization some
of that stuff is going on today maybe
you
and i can go into that a little bit more
active measures exactly the measures
yeah absolutely we'll get into that and
then obviously with everything that's
going on with russia ukraine today but
before we get started
uh uh uh jack if you don't mind for the
audience that doesn't know your
background even if you just take a
couple minutes for the shorter version
so we can get right into the story i
think it'd be a good idea for some of
the audience to hear about your
background yeah the the short cliff
notes yeah of a rather lengthy biography
born in 1949 in
in the part of germany that was occupied
after world war ii
by the by the soviet army
grew up in
the german democratic republic that
wasn't really democratic it was
communist
lived in east germany for
26 years
graduated with a master's degree in
chemistry
and then
i the long detour began the kgb
recruited me
and i was trained to be an agent i would
initially was supposed to be an agent in
west germany but it turned out that
i displayed a phenomenal talent for
language
and i studied english and i did it well
enough
that they decided to
train me to become an american
moved me to moscow for two years uh
where i had interaction with born
americans
studied a lot of uh
english and
also got
the best training
that is available was available by the
kgb with regard to tradecraft
you know how you operate as an agent in
in
1979 i appeared in new york city and
became jack barsky
so we i took on the identity of a born
american who had passed away at the age
of
11 i believe
he had passed away at the age of 11. yes
the real jedi the real jackpot
and this was a this was
the typical way uh the kgb stole ids in
those days it was possible you could get
a birth certificate uh from anybody you
didn't even have to show that you had a
need or were
justified in asking for a birth
certificate he just got it
what what a story right there by the way
i saw you i think was on march 1st on
fox news on an interview you talked
about the fact that russian spies may be
added today so we'll
there may be some russian spies amongst
us we'll talk about that obviously i
want to get some of your thoughts with
the history of what's going on between
the two but
just just out of curiosity did you have
a chance to watch the documentary uh
ukraine on fire by oliver stone as well
as winter on fire by the one that sean
champagne was talking about have you
seen those two documentaries no i have
not you haven't seen him okay so just an
open-ended question what are your
thoughts about what's really going on
today between ukraine and russia what's
led up to this
what led up to this was uh
the formation of
vladimir putin
the
the the
vladimir putin was a kgb agent in east
germany
in the town of dresden
he was not much of an agent he was
mid-level bureaucrats but
you know when in those days when when
you joined as a soviet citizen you
joined the kgb
you were a flaming communist and a
patriot
okay so and the kgb was what's i mean
that was the elite of the elite right
uh
so he he was a mid-level bureaucrat and
dresden
had the good life because east germany
stand of living was much higher than
in in the soviet union uh he
there's pictures of him he was pretty
chubby he liked the german beer
and
you can't blame him the german beer is
pretty good i mean yes
there's no bad beer in germany
so anyway uh and then there was a a
moment that uh pretty much uh shaped him
ideologically
um it was when uh in 1989
when the wall came down
east german citizens
went stormed a bunch of uh
stasi
offices
and undressed them they went after the
kgb office
uh and uh the kgb the guards wouldn't
let them in and they told him
go away or else we're gonna shoot
so they went away they came back the
next day
vladimir called berlin
and
asked berlin do we have permission to
shoot if they come back
and berlin said
we called moscow they're silent
that was the moment when vladimir
understood that
gorbachev was letting go of east germany
and this uh you know and the idea that
you know he belonged to the most
powerful organization on the planet and
he was he was fundamentally
had no powers to do something
that
was the beginning of vladimir putin who
is today because he sort of inside said
we gotta we we gotta we gotta fix this
meaning we can't let this happen because
it was seven decades of control
essentially yes we gotta fix this we uh
we we're losing the greatness that we
were and you know and then
not much later the soviet union fell
apart
uh and
this is what vladimir's uh
goal was and still is is reestablishing
the russian empire
and so he's still a patriot mind you i
think he's not a communist anymore maybe
there's some
residual communist thinking but he's a
patriot and he is i believe
a huge narcissist
because you know you put that together
he he thinks he's the only one who can
do what he's trying to do to
you know establish uh the greatness of
russia and build himself a monument
right next to peter the great
and and that is the driving force
behind what's going on in ukraine right
now that's the driving force behind
what's going on ukraine right now okay
do you think the worst is here or do you
think it's gonna get uglier uh i'm
afraid it could get uglier we
there's a very fine line that the the
west
we must walk because
he there's speculation that putin is not
entire entirely sane
well there's insanity and there's
insanity what he's doing actually by
invading ukraine is insane by itself you
know if
if a sane person does not go after uh
women and children but there's a
if it goes beyond that when he's
going crazy
he's got nukes so we got to be really
really careful you know we can't let him
get away with this
but uh
you know
hopefully you know some talks will
happen and hopefully he finds an
off-ramp because
if he stays in ukraine he's done
he will not survive this in terms of you
know long-term the ukrainians will not
allow him to occupy the country without
major damage uh the uh
the fall of the soviet union started
with the debacle in afghanistan right
and this is going
if he occupies all of ukraine you're
going to have in afghanistan
multiplied several times over
do you think he
he watched how things were handled in
afghanistan and the taliban got what 80
billion or whatever the equipment was
and the mishandling of it that was
brought up both by the folks on the left
and the right so it wasn't like a
political side that they're just
disagreeing do you think he saw that as
an opportunity to say this is the time
for us to invade ukraine
yes
yes uh
i don't know if if it was the deciding
factor but clearly it looked like the
americans the american military doesn't
know what they're doing anymore
it appears that the generals actually
had a different plan and were
overwritten by civilians in the white
house who don't don't know what they're
doing
so so i watched this documentary did you
watch the one with uh by oliver stone or
no no i watched first of all oliver
stone interviewed you putin god knows
how many times like 13 14 i don't know
the exact number but multiple times and
he did this documentary and he went to
both sides right
and it tells you the history of ukraine
and russia so one of the concerns for
putin is
a lot of the countries that were part of
ussr are now
part of nato and it's 13 surrounding
countries that are part of nato
surrounding russia that are not part of
nato so to him
that's a threat because nato keeps
getting stronger around lithuania
and yugoslavia at least all the eastern
bloc yeah i mean just take these guys
right and he's sitting there saying what
is nato's vision what are you trying to
do are you trying to control me are you
trying to hold me
you know those are the nations right
estonia latvia lithuania poland czech
slovakia hungary romania sylvania
croatia montenegro all right on their
doorstep right there so he's kind of
like sitting there saying what is going
on here so
then you look at the history
where years ago stalin negotiated a
treaty with hitler to prevent hitler
from invading through ukraine that was
kind of like the arrangement that they
had but germany broke its promise and
attacked russia anyways
launching barbarossa which ended up
being the largest military operation at
the time and at one point
with ukraine this is why nazi keeps
coming up at one point ukraine was
aligned with hitler
and sss i mean with them in 1941 80 000
people from the ukraine ukrainian army
fought for hitler's army yes so this is
the part that gets a little tricky with
what
you know putin's kind of like do you
guys know the history of what's going on
what what do you know about this all
right rich history let me let me please
go a few years prior to that happening
you're you're right on target here and
uh quite frankly
uh this is not being discussed in the
media at all it's like i heard it i
forgot the name i heard a senator the
other day
saying something like ukraine has been a
democracy
for the last uh 30 years that's not true
it was an oligarchy
and it's still very corrupt today it's
not a democracy
so but let me go back to history um
in uh ukraine
beca was sort of annexed by
i think i think it was still under linen
and became part of the soviet union
uh
there
was always and there have always been a
two uh uh populations uh in in ukraine
there was a russian speaking and
ukrainian speaking and the ukrainians
were more to on the polish side
so anyway so the the the western
ukrainians uh there was a separate this
movement they wanted to go get away from
the soviet union
the other thing that happened in
and
that's very interesting the
collectivization
of the agriculture of the soviet union
you know peasants don't like to be
collectivized
they
they they want to own land right
and once you take that land away from
them you take you know their way of life
so there was this phenomenal amount of
resistance and so stalin
found a way to
starve them into submission he
and they were mostly kgb agents and some
others that went into ukraine and stole
all the grain for two years
they were uh
and so the folks that actually
planted the grain and harvested it
had nothing to eat there were four
million
ukrainians that starved to death
in those days
that is
the
reason for the phenomenal hatred that
ukrainians have today
vis-a-vis
the russians even though stalin wasn't a
russian but you know hatred is not
rational
it was hatred against something that
came from the east
and
and so as a result when hitler came in
uh there were enough ukrainians thought
uh who thought you know there was
liberation
it didn't turn out that way but you're
right there were about 80 000 folks that
that
uh fought on in hitler's army there were
uh uh guards in concentration camps
ukrainians who
who committed lots of atrocities the
most uh the most infamous nationalist
was steppen bandera
uh anti-communist he was you know and it
was pro freedom to the point where
he he he pissed a lot of people off well
he was also anti-semitic yeah he was and
and they hated russians that much and
they decided to side with the nazis but
they were the enemy of my enemy is my
friend basically exactly but but they
were also fundamentally evil
and so when putin says you know there's
there's nazis in
in ukraine there's something to it uh
nine and in
2019 ukraine issued commemorative stamps
to honor the 100th birthday of bandera
that's not a good sign
so there are so
that's what i'm saying there's some
stuff that the history that people
i don't know if enough proper
investigative journalism has been done
to know what's going on there's some
guys that are doing it right now but
this anti-semitism
do you know this guy this stephen
bandera guy you know who put him in jail
you know who put him in during world war
ii
germany hitler put him in jail yes i
mean
oh because he was getting two he was too
independent yeah he was too independent
and they feared him so they just
straight up put him in jail and from
jail
he was still inspiring and moving people
from jair he was jailed he was still
sending messages out to people so this
this guy right here if you look at the
screen i don't know if david you can
show it or not
he played a very very big role
uh during that time but i'm sorry
continue well bottom line is i
there there are there's fascist uh nazi
ideologies still in ukraine but it's not
prevalent
you know what we have there there's a
really really good book that was written
by
uh sean walker
who was the correspondent uh for for the
guardian in moscow and he traveled all
over the country and the book uh what's
called the the long hangover it's about
russia of today and he goes into the
russian uh
and uh and ukrainian uh
the relationship
and based on sean's writing that there
are no good people
on either side now that book came out in
2019 that was before zelinski was
elected i think he's a good guy
well if i may
you know the whole
propaganda that putin is using is that
he's going into ukraine to free ukraine
of
nazism that's right the ironic part
about it is zielinski the president of
ukraine is jewish
the first jewish president they've ever
had i believe and also the number two
person the prime minister is also jewish
so it's like i'm trying to draw an
analogy that you're saying of course
there's anti-semites in ukraine i'm sure
that's everywhere that's like saying
there's races in america but we elected
barack obama so
there's always going to be bad actors in
every country yeah but what they're
talking about is the fact that ukraine
flips so much from pro-russia
pro-western pro-ueu pro-russia
pro-western pro-dis so you know it seems
to be like half and half though if
you're closer to the russian side you're
gonna be more pro-russian if you're
closer to the polish side or the eu side
you're gonna be able to
democratic you have the battle of the
victors you know the two victors that
went at it right victor uh
uh yoshkanov uh yochenko and then victor
uh uh pronouncing it yanukovych okay
those two went of it so uh yochikano
his wife was on reagan's administration
okay yeah his wife american yes was on
reagan's i don't know if she's american
but she was on reagan's administration
okay
so and then on the other side with
uh uh yanukovych he was more on the
other side he was more pro russia he was
more let's make it work so
the whole documentary with winner on
fire that sean penn talks about these
kids are all excited students are
excited you know the victor that's on
pro russia sites and we're going to sign
this treaty with eu we're going to sign
this treaty we're going to do this and
then also the last one they're like no
we're not doing it
and then last minute we flipped and
they're not doing it so that led to the
protesting which led to ugly
i don't know if you saw these it was
pretty bad with the protesting and the
writing
and then eventually they get this guy on
uh uh where pope francis comes out and
prays for ukraine on january 26th
of 2014 very interesting at the end of
his prayer they let two doves go okay
very
it's a little creepy if you watch this
they let two doves go when these two
doves are flying no joke a crow and a
seagull attacks the two dove get out of
here and the audience is there like
panicking because it's all symbolism
right everything's over there's about
symbolism
like oh my gosh and they're going back
and forth back and forth back and forth
then eventually the seagulls and the
crow leaves which means that symbolized
before things get better you're going to
make it you're going to survive but
before things get better
you're going to get attacked by kronos
eagles so that's
how some of the folks there take that as
you know things can get pretty ugly and
after that january 24th to january 26
was a day where pope get that message
february 24th is when they fulfill their
coup
victor was kicked out victor called uh
putin putin said you can come and he
went to russia and that's where it was
at and then next thing you know zalinski
shows up in 2019 2020 yeah and you're
saying he's a good agent so
going back to the question that we asked
there's a lot of skepticism right now
about what putin's going to do what
putin's not going to do as a former kgb
member yourself
in situations like this
right like you know yuri talks about
demoralization destabilization
you know crisis
normalization these phases you go
through and he even takes a deeper
propaganda disinformation deception
sabotage subversion espionage all these
things that he talks about
and that's the playbook of kgb let's
just say if it is the playbook of kgb
if you could think
to the best your abilities on what the
kgb was trained to do the true believers
and you've heard putin say there's no
such thing as a former kgb you've heard
them say that before like there's no
such thing as a former country
what do you think his next moves are
what do you think he does in a situation
like this because in the world right now
he's seen like the next hitler
i
don't want to really disappoint you but
that kgb training
um that he brags about
wasn't that good for him he wasn't he
was not he was not a well-trained agent
he uh he's a masterful politician
and clearly you know
he
everybody in the kgb was familiar with
it but that kind of stuff but but that
doesn't mean that they weren't doing it
very well
yes active measures
was uh particularly under andropov and
dropoff actually issued
a rule that every active kgb agent must
be involved in some way doing active
measures so he was very much uh for it
and and there were a number of successes
that they had but it was not on a large
scale and i think i told you it's the
last time that you know to uh they
managed to
uh put to put this the big lie out there
that uh jay atkar hoover was a secret
cross-dresser
and you're saying that was not true it
was not true it was not true
there's a the
um vlasili mutrokin was a kgb archivist
and he smuggled a lot of material out
of of the archives
and uh in his book there's a section
about our active measures and there's a
number of things where they uh where he
says yeah the kgb didn't did this that
for instance the uh kennedy
assassination all the rumors that were
floating around they were initiated by
the kgb and sort of uh placed
into western media a friendly western
media and a sort of left-wingish and
then picked up by the new york times and
so forth uh that was successful but this
massive undermining of western society
that there's no no such word uh
in in mctroken's book uh he actually
says that
the the uh the department that was
responsible for active measures was the
least desirable
you know the agents the good ones all
wanted to live in the west
surprise surprise
and so they had a lot of failures but
they succeeded
in particular
specific situations and
this
you know this is uh you don't have to be
a trained agent uh that's uh
almost all governments do it don't we
you know we have an agenda we
uh
we we have a narrative and uh we only
talk about the stuff that
fits our narrative right
we do it too
on the left and on the right
uh so and as i as i said i think putin
is uh
probably the the smartest politician in
the last 100 years i mean really
think about it he may he may maintain
power for 20-plus years
in a country where the standard of
living has not really improved
he
that means
he he's a
phenomenal manipulator of his own people
all right they they they're buying into
the the uh you know the tale that that's
that's one of the major narratives that
that
russia is constantly under threat from
from the west and by uh you know having
ex-warsaw pact countries join nato
uh we
gave him some ammunition i'm not saying
we shouldn't have let them into nato but
but there's some reality to it and uh
as uh people who follow history know
that uh
um
russia has historically always been
under attack since its foundation from
everywhere
and so
in in the in the russian
national
genetic makeup
there is a desire for a strong person a
strong leader
you know this is succession there were
some of the czars then we had lenin we
had stalin
and now it's putin
because they're afraid of yet another
invasion that fear
in my view is
unjustified but you know how do you how
do you get this out of you know
the most primitive part of your brain
fear
now jack do you consider yourself
german russian american all of above
just american now where do you classify
yourself right now so
there's one one
answer i give to this uh today i'm
legally uh intellectually and
emotionally an american
period
with german roots but i wouldn't even
use the hyphenation because
um there's a difference between me and
my my wife she's also
has american citizenship
but uh that she was she's originally
from jamaica when she says we
she means to make her when i say we i
mean the united states and us and them
is determined can you even go back to
germany
i have
russia no you cannot go to russia no not
even close no germany yes though germany
uh i've traveled in in western europe uh
in several countries i also was in
poland
uh russia no you see
when when you
show up there
accidents can easily be arranged and
where russia yeah it's it's it's very
very difficult don't drink what they
give you yeah it's very difficult to
arrange an assassination
on foreign on a foreign land very
difficult and they don't have that many
teams that can do that
but once you show up in moscow
and and you know putin is a master in
sending messages to the world why did he
go off the screen paul
this this was uh you know the the fellow
that uh was poisoned in london
he was already exchanged that's the end
normally in the espionage world uh he
was in jail and he was then exchanged by
the by the brits for uh some folks that
they were holding
uh
that that is the end of the game
and he saw fit to just send a message
you know what
we
we can get we can go after you no matter
what so that's why one
why would i anyway go back to moscow
i've been to saint petersburg and
moscow and there isn't much else to be
seen and i think i think he wants to go
and he wants to go with you because i
think adam likes the russian ladies over
there that's cool there's enough
sunny isles florida
can i ask you a question
this is actually for the both of you
it's
i mean you love america more than maybe
anybody i know and you weren't born here
you've been very explicit that i'm
full-on american i don't even use a
hyphen do you think immigrants who have
left other countries
appreciate and love america more than
natural born citizens no doubt
listen i was walking uh for for
about 10 minutes outside and
in this city here and as i'm looking
left and right and i'm looking oh my god
we're such a rich country it is totally
amazing because i
and immigrants like me
we know where we came from and there
wasn't much there
and and opportunities are everywhere if
you want to take advantage of the
opportunities
um and the one thing that unfortunately
is
not playing as big a role as it should
is that i mostly admire as to use
constitution i i took a college course
i've been like
multi-session course about the
constitution
absolutely brilliant document we're
talking about we're talking about uh
how they uh constructed the government
so that minorities would be protected
as opposed to when you have a democracy
if you if you have 51 percent of the
votes you can do whatever you please and
you can really run rough shot off the
over the 49
so yeah it's incredible structure on how
they had it i mean
hillary clinton and some other people
want to change it
uh to a different model but uh you're
right the structure is a you know what
he means by minorities he doesn't mean
minorities like ethnicity wise mind 49
yeah pat where did your love for america
really manifest uh
listen you know again you have to
sometimes you appreciate a friend when
you have a bad friend sometimes you
appreciate a girl when you have a
bad experience with another girl
sometimes you appreciate a guy you date
based on a different bad experience you
have some of the best things that can
ever happen to you is something bad
that makes you realize listen
it's time to be super grateful what were
you complaining about so
the challenge with america america has a
gratitude problem that's what it is
america's got purely a gratitude and a
prospective problem those two things is
what's hurting america more than i can
tell you uh we lack gratitude we
complain too much we act like victims
and we don't realize that this is the
greatest country in the world still
and uh
rather than doing something with
everything that's given to you you
complain about it that's the biggest
thing with me this is the greatest
country there but going back to can i
chime in just
with one with one
thing i want to say americans write
not all but a large majority of
americans are either fat dumb and happy
or fat dumb and angry
we're fat we're the the most overweight
nation of this in the civilized world 36
percent overweight
um
we we have dumbed down at least two
generations of young people because
we're not teaching critical thinking
anymore
and depending you either we're either
happy because we you know we we love
entertainment sports and the tv and
binge watching all that and then we get
angry
uh
when things don't work when we
we requested each other in social media
that's that's a this is a systemic issue
in society
that doesn't seem to have a good outcome
if we don't find a way to
no i agree with you it's a very weird
dynamic the other day westbrook is
complaining because somebody called them
westbrook
and everybody's coming out and saying
well it's not fair to talk to the person
like that what whatever happened to
you know sticks and bones you know
yeah so whatever happened to you know
people can call you anything you want to
go complain about 40 million dollar your
income okay while you're going to your
nice house people are sitting trying to
make 50 60 grand a year
and they're really having to go through
problems you're worried about somebody's
calling you westbrook because you're not
practicing you're not shooting free
throws well i'll give you one anecdote
that that sings um to your story it's
you know i went to uh the freedom forum
on behalf of uh no theory gary kasparov
invited me i'm sure you're very familiar
with gary kasparov um greatest chess
player uh to ever live
um and i interviewed a lot of
essentially freedom fighters the one
iranian lady that you know with the big
hair and the um
gentleman that i interviewed from
iraq he basically hosts the daily show
in iraq to put it in perspective he's
like a comedian satirist
um
political pundit uh funny guy
and to your point about being you know
fat lazy and happy or
or fat lazy and angry
and watching you brought up reality tv
and just sitting around and just
whatever he said i wish i go what's your
your one wish if you could for the
people of iraq i wish that we could just
sit around and watch reality tv and
that's what i wish for the iraqi people
meaning
that there's so much drama and so much
conflict and so much tyrannical abuse
going on that they can't even just sit
down and watch tv for a half hour and
just watch mindless
[ __ ]
and that's what happens here in america
is that we make our problems so much
deeper than they really are compared to
what's going on in the actual real world
to use a real world uh the problem that
with
america sometimes is that they're
too consumed with entertainment and not
enough comes consumed with
you know
education after graduating from high
school or college education stops for
most people in america uh not most
people in america period most people
right the moment they stop going to
college or they go to high school they
don't read books anymore they don't
finish romance novels and you see the
best movie let me see the best let me
see the best at so entertainment
has a has sucked probably 40 50 percent
of most people's lives where they don't
you know put enough time but at the same
time that is one of our greatest exports
i don't rock and roll entertain no no no
american culture you're talking to a guy
who loves music who's excited about
elvis documentary coming out who
no i i totally get it but i think
there's also an element of
uh of being a little bit more educated
about history of what's really going on
that's what i mean by that absolutely i
mean i i now run into people younger
people you know late teens or early 20s
what whoa kgb what's that
you know the biggest war in history
world war ii and again
and this
mass murder that happened in
in the last century
people don't know yeah
and
if they don't know
they might not see it coming
it's not
totally
uh out of the question that united
states one day becomes a dictatorship
happened in germany
yeah you know so so let's let's go there
let's go there for a second so
uh
nobody thinks uh they're gonna die from
cancer until they have it it's always
like the other person oh the divorce is
never gonna happen to me you know i'm
never gonna get fired i'm never gonna
it's never gonna happen to me
america it's never gonna happen to
america there's no way to happen to
america
what are five signs before something
goes that way that's the real question
like what happens to a nation that was a
democracy that was a republic
that led to the fall of that empire what
are a handful of things well let me tell
you the i think the
in my view the most the biggest sign is
uh
when reason leaves the public discourse
and uh unfortunately there isn't that
much left anymore
you know and go back to critical
thinking you know we're being
manipulated like crazy and you know
are we ourselves immune we're not you
know
how how many how many times uh
do i find something that i believed in
and when i check it out it wasn't true
because you can't check everything right
so
that i think is is the most important
thing the next one
uh believe it or not i think uh humor
when humor leaves society
wait that's kind of time to adam's point
a a person who
cannot make fun of himself
is insecure
a nation that can't look at its own
weaknesses
honestly and make fun of them
is insecure
but can't we also point to what's
happening in russia right now as actual
case example
of where authoritarian regimes start to
take over because russia was you know
marketed as a democracy after the fall
of ussr yeah they had elections let's
put it right yeah elections 90 voted for
food a lot of air quotes going on if
you're not watching this but here's some
of the stuff that cnn covered on cnn
politics
putin's autocratic vision for the
russian world here are the highlighted
words censorship
information crackdown mass arrests this
is what dictators do authoritarians
totalitarians
uh democratic experiment has failed but
i mean those types of things you know
you you hear um
if you speak out against the russian
army or whatever you know russians that
you could go to jail for 15 years that
those are actual examples
of where
democracy falls that's the that's the
extreme uh
um
feature of
cancel culture right beyond
yeah that's the extreme we
we cancel you not just your ability to
speak right
yeah 13 000 people arrested on mass
arrest
facebook and twitter is now down over
there you can't use facebook or twitter
in russia
uh but but i wanna go back to putin i
wanna go back to putin okay
you think what like right now uh half
the battle of going up against the enemy
is trying to figure out what his next
three five ten moves are gonna be right
and you said something you said this
could get pretty ugly quickly so we have
to make sure we
are moving accordingly with this guy
what do you think are his if you were to
speculate obviously nobody knows we're
not in a man's mind but here's a former
kgb member you're saying he's the
greatest politician on what he was able
to pull off what do you think are his
next three five moves
well i do believe that uh he has
as his
primary goal
uh the occupation of the eastern part of
ukraine
that may include kiev or may not
uh
i if he if he's still
reasoning and smart he knows he can't
occupy all of
all of ukraine without getting into it
in afghanistan type situation
that will eventually
be his undoing
um and and it's not because
there's demonstrations and russians
i think the majority of the russians
don't want this war but it's
you know
interesting map right here by the way
yeah yep
uh
dictators
can be deposed
uh there there's
palace crews in history all over the
place
and uh
putin needs to be aware that
i'm sure he is aware that the the his
inner circle
they're powerful people
and and he needs to
uh find a way to stay at the top
that means
uh you know
he showed proper aggression
because he they're looking for a strong
man
uh but he can't
get to a point
where
uh his his
his rule is eroded because of uh the
quagmire in ukraine
so i heard this morning
that uh
there are negotiations going on where
there is a little more
uh
realism in the demands on on either side
i think he needs to find an off ramp
if he doesn't
he's done
elaborate on what he's done unpacking
he's done as a person as an individual
they think someone's going to take him
out
uh yeah
you mean not not immediately and and
maybe not necessarily killing but you
know
taking him out because he has he
politically taking him out or
politically or literally taking him out
no no politically uh
did you see that there's a picture in
the in the media where he's surrounded
by
uh all his bodyguards i mean
they are the best trained
uh uh
commandos in the in the world i would
think so he would be hard to take out
unless
and
i'm not advocating any of that
unless you know where he is and and
throw a nuke into that you brought up
his inner circle right the russian
oligarchs i don't know maybe political
well look interesting generals the uh
the the the
intelligence services they all have
power on their own who do you think he
actually listens to
nobody really knows that
right
and there's also no uh no clear
succession plan
you know he's going to be 70 very soon
it's not clear who would succeed him so
that's
until 2036 i believe
if you live that long that's a weakness
of the state if you don't have a
successful play it could be chaotic once
once he disappears
um
it's it's that the the future of russia
doesn't look very good because right now
economically he's he's getting killed
crushed yeah 60 right up crushed
absolutely 40 percent the
currency is dropped in the last whatever
eight nine ten days
and they want to get 60 trillion rubles
back from the people i mean that's
insane if you do something like that
what's this right here lindsey graham
stands by call for someone in russia to
assassinate putin i saw that a few days
ago right he should shut up already you
can say that in private lindsey graham
yeah
but by the way you saw you saw the fact
that an insider from russia released
information that there's already been
three assassination attempts on zelinski
uh oh and
nobody and then the questions asked how
many assassination attempts have been
made on putin nobody knows right because
it have to be from the inside yeah yeah
but there's already been three by the
way you know how many assassination
attempts there was on hitler 42 plus
right and eventually he killed himself
killed himself yeah so do you have an
opinion on who you think putin would
listen to
i i i think i think putin's a true
believer you have to negotiate with true
believers in a different way like you
ever talk to somebody and say but you
don't understand what he did
but you will never understand it but you
will never understand no matter what you
say that person goes to what but you
will never understand it like there's so
much
emotion behind it how do you eliminate
all that emotion
if if that's any like like
parents get a divorce my mom and i got a
divorce no matter what's said
that
the emotion is so deep between the two
nobody can do anything about it right
it's that deep of what that emotion is
you just heard the history of what
happened with russia and how
it went back and forth and how he views
ukraine and what he thinks of ukraine
you know what he thinks about him
he looks at zelinski and he says this is
not a leader i would do laps around this
guy how do you guys buy
into an actor being your president who
created a political party on a tv show
and he starts uh
i don't look at trump but but i i
totally but to him yeah you got to think
about to putin to putin is like who are
you to sit across like who do you think
you are you're a nobody putin's a true
believer so
you know for me i already said it
yesterday when we talked about it i
think the best offense is what
what what do you found a good defense
america had a good defense prior to
biden
america had a pretty good defense prior
to biden biden's not scaring anybody so
everybody's playing offense because our
defense sucks right now defense is how
you handle afghanistan that's a terrible
defense
we did not have a good offense you don't
intimidate anybody when you don't have
so
what do we do about it so he's being
opportunistic about it
my only concern is again it goes back to
the same thing my only concern is
how far is he willing to go out the
reason why i called jack this week and i
said jack we want to have you on and we
i we just called you this week by the
way or maybe sunday or monday no it was
friday actually monday was monday okay
it was monday so monday two days ago
right outside i'm real quick yeah and we
we threw him out because i want to know
what he's thinking and i want to know
what his moves are going to be
what what is a formula yeah i want to
know what
is is how much of it is a bluff game
how much of um we don't know that's what
i'm saying you've used the analogy
multiple times that he's you know he's
got pocket twos and he acts like he's
you know has a straight in his hand
you've used this analogy yeah i i wonder
like is he bluffing because
he's so into deep now
that it's very hard to paint a picture
for him to redeem himself history may be
done with him like you have to realize
history he's a pariah on the world stage
no doubt at this point but just three
weeks ago just two months ago it wasn't
though that's my point yeah but history
may be done with him so in his mind
is he sitting there like hey i was doing
this for my dad i was doing this for my
legacy i was doing this for my mother
russia i was doing this for this
who is his loyalty to is it is he
worried about the people around him that
are upset with him that he may lose
power to somebody that wants to replace
him because he's 69 years old right now
is he thinking that
his loyalty is to himself first of all
secondly i want to add a feature here
uh when you you had zilinski's picture
up there
he doesn't look like a
strong individual
physically putin has a black belt in
karate
putin has
cultivated an image of being a real
tough guy
uh you you know that infamous picture of
him riding a horse
no shirt on no sure
and
for quite some time i think he stopped
doing as he got too old he would have
participated in a hawk in a hockey game
annual hockey game where he and four
others took on the starting five of the
national team yeah and putin always
scored the goals
right he always had a hat trick against
the best players in the world exactly so
right so ridiculous
this this is so ridiculous but he
believes that he can pull it off and he
actually seems to be pulling it off
because i have a video of one of the
games and you know he scored a goal in
twitter in the first 20 seconds and
everybody screams yeah
so so that's that's kind of like when
you let the little kid run down the
football field and all the yeah the
tacklers move out of the way and the
six-year-old scores a touchdown i mean
that's essentially what he's doing it's
propaganda so so he has created that
image of himself as a strong man and he
believes in it
because you know if
well more importantly than he believes
in it the russian people believe in it
yes how do they fall for the propaganda
propaganda time and time again
especially with them well and
i i've been lately uh watching quite a
few documentaries about uh
you know how hitler came to power and
and how he
uh he ran the third reich
how did the germans believe all that
nonsense how would they all go like this
in unison uh
and
and and that wasn't an educated populace
do you think putin is an extremely
sensitive guy
yes and i tell you he's hypersensitive
okay so
you know why i'm asking that i think you
know where i'm going with this do you
think he's super hypersensitive yes and
i tell you why i know this um
and there's a there's a fellow by the
name of oleg kalugin
uh he was uh kgb he was in charge of uh
counterintelligence
for the first directorate first
directorate was espionage i was in the
first directorate
and
at one time he was
vladimir's boss
and i met olek a couple of times he
lives in the united states he's a
citizen
and uh
he
said you know
he wasn't he wasn't much of a good agent
but there's he said there's one thing i
will not do
he i will not say anything i will not
attack him personally
apparently he may know something that
would uh
be putin's on doing
talk talking about sensitivity and i'm
not gonna
mention that on on air so there were
some hints but
there
apparently it's a great great
sensitivity because of that ego the
narcissism right
and uh there has to be there has to be
something that to be at that level you
have to be hyper sensitive about
something and and and running around uh
you know american politicians and
calling them all kinds of names is is
not necessarily doing us any good and it
could just i don't i don't disagree make
it more crazy i don't disagree yeah i
don't care why do you ask that question
hypersensitive yeah oh all i'm saying is
if you're dealing with somebody
hypersensitive you have to
the ability to tame yeah is is is a
political uh
skill like he's got they got
yeah
so the more sensitive he is the more
dangerous he is to the world and i think
he's very sensitive i think he's
extremely hyper sensitive so i think
whoever makes the next moves with them
they have to make it the right way by
the way props to zielinski for not
attacking back in
doing any of that he's he's saying
listen man i'm not i'm just fighting you
back but i'm not hurting you yeah
they're taking the soldiers and they're
holding the soldiers and the soldiers
are apologizing they're making a video i
don't know if you've seen those videos
where the soldiers who ukraine takes
from russia russians and they're
prisoners of war they're saying on video
man i'm sorry i'm just doing my job
they're just telling me what to do
there's hundreds of these by the way no
no no not propaganda actual russian
soldiers no meaning that's what they're
using to win the hearts and minds of
other people yeah so so what is it is it
fear do you fear it
are you worried what could happen are
you worried what he's going to do and so
you said something he said his loyalty
is only to himself
i don't know if i i
i believe that i think i think it is to
himself but i think it's
it's is it a lenin is it a stalin is it
a there's got to be something more than
that and to be able to handle this guy
you got to do it in a very it's too late
the strategy of trump doesn't work with
biden right now you can't go from not
being a tough guy to being a tough guy
yeah like remember when ted cruz and
marco rubio all of a sudden started
talking trash to trump yeah it didn't
work and everybody's like what the hell
are you doing that's not your identity
stop it you look funny you're not a
troll trump's a troll you're not a troll
yeah don't try to play in the mud yeah
yeah
this guy's been a troll for his entire
life he's a pro he comes from the
streets of new york he's a tough guy
you're not a tough what are you doing
ted what are you doing so did a lot of
good luck so bite can not play the card
of trump trump's been that he's i don't
think he's trying to though no he's not
he's not trying to and i think for the
most part especially with the um
the address he gave last week i think
biden has looked
capable i'm not i don't think he's
looked strong or tough but it looked
like he's making sense and yeah i can't
i agree i can't disagree with the way we
have been handling the situation i
cannot
um now
the only thing
that
clear thinking
people
disagree with is that we were not
opening up
the american oil spigot again
right which i think is coming
i think that's the next step because we
just put a ban on
russian oil right right we're too busy
courting
iran and venezuela and everybody else
why would we open up our own pipelines
yeah i mean that's that that right there
if you think about that that is the the
matter of fact i'll read that story go
to page two down below uh uh papa papa
which one is that banjo don't you think
yes
administration courts venezuela iran and
saudi arabia by the administration of
course venezuela i ran in saudi arabia
for oil while ignoring u.s producers the
has found themselves in a position where
they need more oil
production to lower gas prices but can't
do that domestically without alienating
the large anti-fossil fuel portion of
the base and breaking their own promises
at gas prices top four dollars
nationally and seven dollars in some
cities there instead opting to beg
venezuela iran and saudi arabia for
bailout this comes days after biden
proved the release of 30 million barrels
from the strategic petroleum reserve for
reference 30 million barrels isn't even
enough to cover two days of u.s oil
consumption with the possible exception
of saudi arabia biden would rather fund
a list of america's enemies than boost
our own oil industry
so so you got russia what they're going
through you got us how we're reacting to
economical crisis that we're having here
today right these are two different
things that's going on that's putin this
is u.s and biden every time he's asked
he was asked a question yesterday i
don't know if he saw that tyler he was
asked are gas prices going to go up yes
what are we doing about it we can't do
nothing about it it's because of russia
he said that yesterday in a
question back i don't know if you saw
that or not person asking that question
so
lower and middle income families are
paying a price for this that's what
that's who's paying a price for that
that's a completely different
conversation this is another case where
uh um
ideology is trumping reason and i'm not
using trump because of donald trump this
is
this is an ideology
the queening of the world
it it no matter how you look at it
what we're doing here doesn't make any
sense
because
american companies
pump oil cleaner and produce whatever
the the derivative of oil
much cleaner than all the other
countries
so
it doesn't make it doesn't make any
sense there's it's no clear thinking
it's an ideology it's a religion
with greater is the
did you see the story about saying did
you see the story from l.a times and all
over the place whether vladimir putin is
terminally ill and dying of cancer
a former russian intelligence officer
and others believe so did you see that
story i didn't say
and i believe it when vladimir dies from
cancer okay so you think that's another
story that's being made out of yeah one
on one reason why many people think in
uh uh russian president vladimir putin
executed the invasion of ukraine so
quickly and suddenly he's dying
according to reports citing a former
russian intelligence officer who now
works for the pentagon putin could be
suffering from terminal
bowel cancer his puffy face seen in
images this year could indicate he is
undergoing chemotherapy treatments on
steroids the daily star reported this in
their story that quoted the source the
source says this diagnosis could have
encouraged him to be more aggressive and
attack ukraine so he can leave a legacy
knowing he is dying he added that
analysis have been studying putin who
think he has a terminal illness
and here's another source quoted from
the daily start in the past we've seen
him smile but in 2022 there are a few
pictures of him looking happy his look
suggests he is in pain and our people
suggest his angry look is most likely as
a result of being in agony or people are
confident he is ill he is concerned
about covet as he keeps his staff as a
at a distance
uh
how much credibility do you think
there's behind
this uh
none i mean i mean how would you ever
even
so so this guy the ex-intelligence agent
is a doctor a medical doctor he can you
can see this i i could i could
understand that
vladimir doesn't sleep very well these
days works really hard so that shows in
your face and
this is just wishful thinking and you're
muddling the picture
just you got to deal with what you know
is the truth well remember when they did
this with kim jong-un for like a couple
months they were like yeah he's sick
we found his twin it's not really
strategy he's gaining weight he's got
the gap what is the strategy
to do what oh it's just the story you're
saying it's just to get views
okay no but what i'm saying is why is a
intelligence guy that now works at a
pentagon what is his motive to release
that not not media he's not trying to do
clickbait what's his motive to get his
name out i mean how big of how big of an
official i would be so upset if you were
working for me i'm like what the hell
are you doing
what are you doing to get your name out
you think this is one of the best things
that chief disguise officer cia agent
jonah mendes told me she said the best
qualities about a ci agency intelligence
agents is what you're charming you're
charismatic you're this your dad you're
this you're handsome you're a great
salesman but when you save the world
from world war three you don't tell
anybody about it because you don't need
the recognition she said that's equality
don't be an intelligence
character by the way i get it but we
have all those great qualities and don't
tell anybody my question would be is how
high ranking is the official i mean
remember anonymous that was supposed to
be this super high-ranking trump
official that wrote the big paper back
in what 2017. you saw anonymous came out
the other day right and he was a
low-level staffer that nobody knew i i
would venture to say it's it's similar
with this guy okay let's talk about
russian spots here's a story about
russian spies okay on page three
and and i'm curious to know how much
credibility you're giving to this one
russian spies among us a look at new
york compound that houses kremlin's
intelligence officer the complex
known as russian diplomatic compound in
new york city's riverdale neighborhood
has often been the subject of
speculation surrounding the building's
purpose and residence practices the
building is home to russian diplomats
many of whom work in the united states
as intelligence officers there are two
types of intelligence officers those who
pose a symmetrical threat and those who
pose
an asymmetrical thread those working in
new york and living in the compound and
working at the mission in the united
nations are under diplomatic cover it's
called a symmetrical threat we know
they're here they're diplomats under
diplomatic coverage so they actually
have all the privileges of diplomats and
they've been caught conducting coverage
so they actually
espionage against our country you can't
throw them in jail because they're
diplomats but they're different from
undercover operatives who are not
uh under the official cover and are in
the united states those who pose as
asymmetrical
uh threat undercover operatives such as
jack barsky who operate under
non-official cover under false pretenses
with fake names
what do you want to say that article
fails to mention the third category
what's that
people who
are
not undercover they're not
assuming another identity they work
officially as
as journalists
uh business people
students
right they they
they have an official reason to be here
but then they spy and i think those are
the ones right now that uh
that we we have to be aware of uh
because you know we are very open
country how many how many chinese
exchange students do we have
uh in and i guarantee you
russia and china
and all those dictatorships know exactly
who is going abroad
and they all will be talked to
so there's there's a good there's a good
reason to believe that there are
currently more
people in the united states russians
that
are engaged in espionage than they were
in my time
because there wasn't in my time there
wasn't that free exchange of you know
students and
teachers and uh
and business people uh
back and forth
there in those days we had the two types
the asymmetric threat
us and there were very few of us very
few the in the
undercover yes
deep cover yes
uh
in in the 80s according to mitrokin uh
there were
early 80s late 70s there were about 10
10 of us that were
uh trained and sent to the u.s
10.
uh and there were a couple of other
prior to the uh to that period there
were
um there were a couple of other uh
efforts to bring
those types of agents into the u.s and
they never amounted too many okay uh
so
and and here's here's one other
difference between
the
uh kgb and
putin's intelligence services
the kgb was very solicitous of their
agents they were
they
did not like it when an agent was caught
they weren't you know they did and and
if we if and when we were caught they
did everything to get us out
uh putin
enjoys when we catch people
because you know
it scares us you know how many more of
those are there
i guarantee you quite a few oh he likes
it when we catch people why not because
it makes them it gives a message it
gives a message that we got on the
inside yes and we're here it's game
we're not going anywhere it's
gamesmanship
how many
reverse it how many people how many
americans or you know people on the
american side of things or on the eu
side of things even are
implanted in russia or even china for
that matter
i would that's this is an educated guess
far fewer
far fewer they're better at it than we
are yes they are and um
or it's just easier to blend in in
america how many people want to live in
russia how
how uh bernie sanders
yes and how many people would uh you
know it would be a sacrifice as opposed
to coming to the united states you get a
good life and you do something patriotic
for your country
that also played a role
for me signing up in those days but like
you how many people fall in love with
the benefits of living in america and
say
kgb life ain't for me anymore i'm just
going to stay here for a while
yes but you've got to be careful there's
always relatives in back home
and you may be married and with children
so
and it's not that easy to defect and you
know and if you want to play
the double agent game that's very
dangerous and the people that uh the the
this category of uh
uh
official cover but but not
under diplomatic protection
uh
this category is not well trained they
don't get normal you say when in 2010 uh
there were like 10
uh
sv svr agents uh russian agents were
arrested by the
by the fbi and they were like very
poorly trained there's a there's a short
video an fbi video on youtube where you
can see
some of their operations and when i saw
this for the first time i was screaming
at the tv you can't do this this is
wrong
what what role you think what role you
think uh
um
ngos play
you know what ngos are not what i know
you think they play like hey we're just
the charity here oh not a governmental
organization we're creating it here and
humanitarian we're here to save your
country and help you out in a meanwhile
behind closed doors they're playing
their games and
uh yes and historically even the kgb did
a really good job
infiltrating ngos in those days
uh
yes uh
you got to be wary of those
why why is that well
because you know they have a they
operate under a cover and many of them
stand for a good cause so they can
attract people to do something
for them under false flag
let's say some kind of a peace
organization we are for peace in the
world
and then you can
under this flag you can
recruit somebody who has access to
secrets
state department
you know just like help us out you know
we we need to have equality in the world
how does the country
that knows what the motive of many ngos
are how do you
say oh yeah yeah come on in here we know
you guys want to do good come come help
us out
why why do why do they
permit for that take to take place this
is a guess but uh you know if you you
you attack the
groups that are serving a good cause
you've got a pr problem
a big one
right
like i mean you know uh did you see what
award hillary clinton got from forbes
yesterday can you go to is forbes
instagram account yesterday by the way
did you see it i think i sent it to you
this morning yeah i sent it to you this
morning yesterday international what oh
you didn't see this
uh uh obviously she's known as the
biggest sweetheart you go to go to
instagram and then type in forbes
uh just type in instagram forbes i want
to i want to read this to you because
then i want i want you to see the
commentary
um
so
yesterday they posted this go to right
there okay click on that
and make it bigger so we can see the
comments as well
uh
uh uh make it bigger in the in the
comment section it's important to the
world
uh i think if you care about your own
not this one no not this one they give
the right yeah they i think if you can't
reference them or something they gave
her recognition yesterday and it was on
instagram
um anyways she got the recognition as a
women
um
let me see this here
where is that at uh
hillary
clinton receives forbes international
women's day lifetime achieve award right
that's the one uh i don't know if you
have that or not they posted that but i
want you to go to the commentary is that
the one no okay
anyway so so if you go to the comment
section with that and what people are
saying
uh they're saying wait is this a joke
are you serious is this real uh are you
really recognizing her for what she's
got
you remember when she was going through
uh go to comment section
uh and i'm out thank you forbes she got
a puffed up face maybe she has cancer
too but she's smiling so she's probably
happy right
if she didn't win forbes would be
committed suicide
the point is this
she was the one that went to haiti for
humanitarian causes right to help out
haiti and then all of a sudden a few
billion dollars went missing i may be
wrong but i remember reading that story
yeah i i met uh
a diplomat
a while ago who from haiti and i asked
him uh how much of that money went
to the people who needed it and he said
zero
but it was such a marketing campaign yes
and so achievement award what did she
achieve uh reset with russia
you know that sent the signal also to
europe that it was okay you know russia
will be okay we could play ball together
and and that
that
helped putin to create this energy
dependency
that western europe has on
on russia right now
and what an achievement what an
achievement by force you've given this
to oprah oh you're kidding me
you're right the other name like why i
don't understand the fascination with
hillary clinton legitimately like what
what has she done specifically to earn
this award it's another word that starts
with the letter f but it's not
fascination it's called fear
okay it's called fear it's not
fascination it's why are people afraid
let's just give a recognition to get on
our good side you don't know what's
going on by the way first of all 95 of
forbes is now owned by china and malcolm
malcolm forbes is right now probably in
his grave
you know turning saying why did you sell
a company that's all about the
capitalist tool to china why would you
what does that steve forbes have to say
currently with steve forbes i i don't
understand that concept i i don't
understand he's constantly on forbes i
mean i'm sorry on fox giving his
opinions i'd love to interview him i'd
love to have him
can you invite him can you have rob
let's let's see if we can get him here
because i'd be curious to know what uh
why you would do such a thing but let me
continue let me continue with a couple
other stories here that we've got going
on
uh
we're going to airfields which one was
it that we wanted to go through okay
yeah russians offering syrians 300
to fight in ukraine
uh uh
u.s european allies discussed banning
imports from russia obviously u.s
already did it
uh by banning it but now other countries
are also talking about they may be doing
it europe relies on russia for crude oil
and natural gas but has become open the
idea of banning russia probably they've
already done that but then you've got a
few other countries that are looking at
that uh look how do you stop this right
now if if you wanted to stop this right
now with them like if you were to say
here's this country is going to matter
that country is going to matter this
country is going to matter this
sanction is going to matter this
challenge is going to matter this fear
is going to matter how do you stop putin
right now
now you got to be stick to your guns and
be consistent
and i'm a little bit concerned
with
possibly the german government for
instance
getting too aggressive because believe
it or not
when i went back to germany
and
there was during the trump
administration
the germans i talked with
would have sided with putin over
donald trump
the germans the german population forgot
what the united states did for them in
world war ii and so there is a
significant
and i i've i've i've had some emails are
coming out of germany significant
segment of the population that is
actually on putin's side and germany has
elections so now see this is where it
gets really uh difficult
uh inside why
why
oh a friend of mine
who
who um
best my best friend who was uh
who worked as a chemist in the stasi um
headed to forgery department so he still
has some
my generation has residual
communist ideology they couldn't get rid
of it completely
and so
they're looking at russia
sort of uh
with with a whole lot more sympathy and
and this friend of mine who's very
bright
uh
thinks this whole thing
has been engineered by the united states
because uh the united states biggest aim
is to
separate germany
and and russia so to speak because
a union sort of a coalition of germans
and russians could be a a strong uh
counterforce against the united states
germans don't like the united states
that's a there's a fact you know with a
big bully
uh and and it's a shame so
um
and and friends you know the french
don't like us as much either
i mean
at least enough of them and so
it's
it's a it's a difficult um
you know balancing act here to
you know
you want to stick to your guns you know
it's gonna it's gonna get painful for
europe
more so than us um yeah when you look at
the map you know
the conversation we had yesterday about
the fact that hey us your neighbors are
who canada and mexico what are you
afraid of right nothing you got canada
you got mexico everybody else you got to
fly a long ways to come here right who's
the neighbors of russia shoot china
all these other nato nations
you know if you just look at that map
right there of
russia get get can you make that bigger
for us to see it just make it bigger
okay there you go so you got russia
you've got ukraine belarus another
biggest country in the world they're
surrounded by
all sides yeah so it's um
but you're saying german is
playing a different role now meaning
they're kind of aligning themselves with
russia no no no no no i'm talking about
the german population oh i got you
talking about the people who vote the
the german government surprised me
phenomenally because you know what was
supposed to be
a more conservative government under
merkel
uh
was really weak and and this socialist
just made a radical 180 degree
about phase about his stance towards uh
defending his own country that's what
trump wanted them to do you know and
that's they hated trump for that because
he walked into germany and told him you
know come on and pay up
and do something for in your own defense
so so so he's now committed to to
spending two percent of his gnp on on
defense
and uh you know the the and he's he's uh
pretty aggressive with the embargo
i they're talking about even not buying
or natural gas that would be a huge
problem because you know under angela
merkel they
they had a very very uh
poorly um
arranged uh
energy policy you know when they
when you go to germany nowadays you see
windmills all over the place
and and they
their electricity is like three times
more expensive than ours because you
know
they they shut down the nuclear plants
so what's the whole concept of the
nordstream 2 they're going to shut that
off tyler i know you uh done some
research on that right
well yeah so nordstrom 2 was a pipeline
that would go direct from russia to
germany and skip ukraine ukraine makes
like five billion dollars a year
transporting oil from russia to germany
and this would go straight to to germany
from russia and right excuse me germany
buys i think 40 of their oil comes from
russia so everybody wants to talk about
american energy independence gas prices
that we were exporting oil to the rest
of europe energy is
a form of defense and it can be
manipulated into
not a form of war but but uh almost
again again a form of defense so if we
if we export oil to europe we can make
europe stronger by cutting off
dependence on russian oil saudi oil
iranian oil venezuelan oil etc etc so
it's so it's so much bigger than just
lowering the price at the pump i mean we
were we were a net exporter under
president trump and as soon as
president biden came in that's that's
switched and gas prices have been up
and rising since the beginning of joe
biden's presidency this didn't start
with russia ukraine i mean at the
beginning of his presidency gas prices
started rising
and it isn't just the gas because of uh
because everything else that we buy
somehow is impacted by the energy prices
and that's what
and if biden thinks he can get a grip on
inflation because it's going to get
worse yeah yesterday i was consulting
with this one guy who owns a
construction company and they do not
construction company transportation
company truck so he does loads
and he says i got a question for you so
what's that he says you know
prices for my uh
loads that i'm delivering it's gone up i
said by how much he says yes i mean 25
and i don't know how to talk to my
customers about it so you got to be open
about it they know what's going on with
gas prices he says but a lot of them are
not open to the idea i said it doesn't
matter you got to have a conversation
with them right meaning hey instead this
is going to cost three thousand dollars
it's gonna cost now thirty seven hundred
dollars what do you mean you're gonna
increase it by that much so he the
person that's transporting is going to
say what well i was normally paying
three thousand dollars to transport now
i have to pay thirty seven hundred
dollars to transport it's up twenty two
percent so this product that you
normally would buy for three dollars is
now three dollars and seventy five cents
okay this product you buy that's ten
dollars now twelve dollars i don't have
a choice gas prices is not just about
what it costs to go to the gas station
no it's about transportation but exactly
think about everything that's made with
oil over six thousand products are made
with water that doesn't exactly that
doesn't include everything that's made
with adhesives with plastics
with rubber vests everything is touched
by oil i mean prices yeah it's so much
more than just again medication drugs
by the way with with this going on right
now uh jack who who is happy
okay who which world leader right now
sitting around saying i'm so glad this
is going on because it took so much
distraction off of me china i agree and
why do you think they're happy what do
you what do you think they're well
they're sitting back
right and they're watching
this
fundamentally
the the western alliance and russia are
weakening each other right now
no doubt about it there's no clear
winner
china sitting back is not involved and
they're just waiting to see when they
can strike
against taiwan you're saying no sure
and that's the likelihood that that
happens
i don't know
um
it it's probably more than fifty percent
for them to get theirs is gonna be a lot
easier by the way because
because they've been statings for
you know the one china policy is
official policy they're just waiting for
the right time to do this
and you know this looks pretty good
right now for that in mind
i mean
what
we already like
the united states their main enemy is
already pretty much focused on russia
now so what are we going to do when they
when they start taking over time well
here's a different perspective is there
any doubt that china could just go take
over taiwan in a day or two done right
yeah
people also said that about
ukraine
right and ukraine is kind of holding
their own but the backlash is what i'm
referring to
the pariah that putin is becoming china
is kind of teetering like they've been
doing this balancing act where they're
yeah they're kind of like this bad actor
but people are still kind of doing
business with them and
and buying products but
if they invade taiwan where do you think
the global sentiment will will direct
itself against china well basically as
the big bully but i don't think so it
will be harder
to boycott china than it is to boycott
russia simply because you would empty
all the walmart shelves
you know
everything that i buy is made in china
these days right
so
and including including uh you know
medications and stuff like that
things that are important
we have let go
of control and i think it had something
to do with the
unregulated capitalist greed follow the
money
it's not a rosy picture that
and
i don't know
you've got to hope that the chinese
really
like the way they're going now you know
um you know stealing secrets from the
united states uh you know and uh
and doing great business with the united
states which helps them
uh controlling their own population you
know by building these these
uh you know the the capability to
supervise the population and like
centrally control everything that
everybody's doing so
that's that's a uh
that's a calculus that i don't know how
strong it is you know whether they want
to continue
living the rich life you know the the
upper class
or
not
well here's the other part that you
gotta think about go go to maps go to
maps just just go to uh
not that map just go to regular put
taiwan and then just go yeah taiwan
and map okay
so here's a couple things you got to
think about but go to the map on google
map not the images just click on map
right no no just right there below it
and just go to maps right there there
you go
so if you go to map
and go to taiwan okay
so uh go a little closer okay so so to
the left go a little bit out a little
bit out a little bit out they go to the
left is hong kong okay now you got to
realize hong kong for 156 years was part
of a
british you know the brits had hong kong
right and in 19 what is it 1997 late 90s
they get it back okay all right so say
hong kong asks for help who do they call
say taiwan asks for help guys help us
now zoom out a little bit zoom out a
little bit okay we're on our way
yeah yeah we're on our way guys we'll be
there in a minute
we'll be there in six hours oh japan
we're gonna get involved and help you oh
we're going to get involved and help you
and then uh no it's done right now go to
ukraine now go to ukraine so just go to
the other side just move them under you
don't need to put the name there just
move the map yeah so keep going left
keep going left keep going left keep
going left okay now look at ukraine go
down a little bit to see russia and
ukraine hey guys i need help boom we're
there
yeah okay so so the taiwan is going to
be a a lot different than
a ukraine's uh going to be it was not
that they're not going to have a hard
time doing that but i do agree with the
fact that this now here's the other
question what are the chances
what are the chances that there was a
conversation between xi and putin where
putin and xi talked about hey uh
you're calling us the most important
strategic partner the foreign mineral
russia is our most important
you know strategic partner right that's
the word now what are the chances of xi
and putin having a conversation together
saying look
you know no cameras no nothing no one's
around nobody knows this conversation
i know what you want they talk in code
and you know what i want
do you think this is a good time for me
to go do it
do you think there's any kind of a proxy
type of thing where she is like i think
this is a perfect time to do it like
giving him cover no you know what it's
kind of like adam i think can be tighter
i think this is the time you should
do you think somebody poked him to do it
or no do you think putin didn't need
anybody to poke him like she didn't try
to create a proxy war it's a good guess
it's a good guess that they had like
face-to-face conversation and
off the record so to speak you know hint
yeah but do you think do you think there
is any chance that she would say i would
if i were you right now you know i i
think it's a good time right now to do
it
do you think that kind of a conversation
would take place or no plausible
deniability would uh indicate that you
don't say it directly and openly they
just hint
got it
i agree like you you you
do you do you do it directly or do you
use a third party to go deliver that
message to his camp
right are you suggesting that putin
would want
to get
she's
you know green light in order to invade
ukraine yeah i mean i i wonder like i
wonder what is the level of unity
between the two guys because bringing
the map out bring the map out
bring the map out look at china look at
russia they're talking to each other
they're right there all right on the
eastern side of the country they touch
you they are not justified
this is a marriage of convenience uh
ideologically they are different uh
putin is also looking to retain
influence
in the former republics that have asians
living in them and that that border on
china
uh i guarantee you that there's
conflicts okay and there has been that's
good history of shooting at each other
at the border no major conflict but
then they're not best buddies but you
know when it comes to
their main enemy they are somewhat
united against the united states that's
very good news that they are not
bodybuilding if if it's true yeah if
it's true they're almost more
they're it's an alliance they're not
natural partners i mean they're almost
like we covered this yesterday russia is
still selling weapons to
india
for india to prepare against the fight
against china i mean they're not
partners g
g has has bigger goals than just being
friends with vladimir putin i mean it's
it's
why
i think the best thing we can do is
really
which joe biden has done to his credit
is stay out of ukraine and out of this
conflict and not push vladimir putin
into the arms of xi jinping because the
big question becomes what happens when
china invades taiwan what do we do do we
put boots on the ground is that when we
step in i mean i think it's inevitable
so what happens when that becomes a
reality is is world war three inevitable
i mean
taiwan makes 60 of the 70 semiconductors
in the world you think you have a chip
shortage now just wait you know taiwan
when when when it gets invaded i don't
think it's an if i think it's a win
is going to be very different than
what's going on in ukraine and the
answer or the question is what does joe
biden do
why would the u.s even attempt to step
into a
taiwanese takeover that's not even
anything that we would even want to
meddle in
you just heard him say the 60 chips
though yeah but that's
you know there's alternative measures
that we can take other than trying to
get into a hot war with china you know
they have the triad that we discussed
yesterday australia japan
um united states and what's the fourth
country uh
what'd you say australia japan united
states and it's not india is it uk you
tell me the tribe is uh
and there's a fourth country involved in
the triad the point is that there's an
alliance created
to
combat
china's influence in the uh south china
sea it might be india
um
but
yeah i i don't think us is looking for a
hot war at all do you think it's just
sanctions like what we're doing with
russia there's got to be alternative
measures here that war is not the answer
here right now and and back to the gas
prices i had a conversation with my mom
yesterday and my mom did zero percent
knowledge about what's going on so i
posed the question i go mom how much
does it cost to fill your tank
she says it costs 40 bucks i said well
you do understand now that gas prices
are rising
she goes yeah i know it cost me fifty
dollars this week to fill my tank
so how often do you fill your tank once
a week so i said it's gonna cost you ten
dollars more
you know in general to fill your tank
she goes
okay
like to combat tyranny
and to stand up
against
autocratic
thinking like putin if it costs my mom
who's a nurse
ten dollars more a week
so be it
you know gas prices aren't the end-all
be-all yes there are bigger things like
the trucker that you talked about and
businesses or people who drive for a
living you know maybe you eat out a
little bit less but you're gonna have to
do something different but for my mom to
spend ten dollars more a week
so be it so so so i will i will uh take
a different position with that
and uh and i'll i'll tell you this so
right now
the the crisis is so bad on the left
that they have to figure out a way
to either take a few different measures
to not make the gas price a massive
issue so they're they're they're facing
a few different problems why are we
having so many
uh uh problems world we didn't have a
war during trump why are we having so
many problems
under this administration why is that
first we have the afghanistan now we
have this first we have inflation gas
prices go up now we have this
why is this happening we just had a
worldwide pandemic so i mean a lot of
this is systemic because of that
right but again so even with the
pandemic throw that in there as well
why why so the
the left has to position everything to
be normal it's okay it's gas prices just
going up it's okay you know it's
inflation it's going to be okay it's
going to go away now it's not really
inflation it's because of this oh it's
really going on because they have to
deflect deflect deflect because midterms
there's an element of it that's politics
but
the part of it that with your mom's
story i'm glad it doesn't affect you the
ten bucks i'm fully glad it doesn't
affect her it affects a lot of people my
believe me my mom is of the elk that it
would affect the comments i i get that
she doesn't by no way means doing but
your mom is also not in the working
environment where she has kids to take
care of where she has expenses to cover
where she has to drop off the kids drive
them to soccer and all that other stuff
she's a retired woman that is not
necessarily have 50 different things to
do when you were 12 years old and when
you were 8 years old it's a different
life for somebody that's going through
that trying to survive on the time like
that but the price increase is going to
be felt and it's not just going to be
gas gas is only one thing we're talking
about just watch all the other prices
and fyi
if you think the gas prices are at the
peak right now
people
are lying to themselves or they're naive
wait till this thing gets to ten dollars
and everybody has to have the real
conversations about
listen i was kind of okay at four
dollars
but
i'm not okay with ten dollars don't you
think at that point a biden
administration will start opening up the
floodgates of oil what's the difference
between starting now and then what is
the difference between that wouldn't be
shocked if they started now
well yesterday they announced that
they're gonna ban russian oil okay so
where do we think we're going to get oil
from okay we're going to have amen
that's why we're no no no negotiations
are happening right yeah there you go so
if you rush a bandwidth russia that's a
very good strategy
for pr that's great to say we're not
doing it with pr great like mcdonald's
we're shutting down 700 stores in russia
starbucks okay this is good you have to
do that because your customers are going
to be like what are you like you know
these
restaurants liquor stores are coming out
and pouring all their vodka you know and
then somebody came back and said the
following they said oh really you're
pouring all this stuff out of vodka why
don't you go throw all this stuff out
that you have in your store that says
made in china if you're really not
committed why don't you go out and drop
all the made in china stuff nobody's
saying that or you're only saying
because this is cool to do that right
you wouldn't even think about doing it
if you were supposed to drop all the
stuff made in china because you do so
much money so there's so much hypocrisy
in this thing right now that you just
you just have to kind of really see
uh what's going on but but this this gas
crisis if it hits 10
and biden's still trying to negotiate
his cap with maduro's camp venezuela or
saudi arabia or they're already in talks
or iran or all these other guys we look
so weak you're negotiating with the
enemy hey
can you please sell us some gas at a
discount please things are pretty bad in
america why don't you go get it yourself
and then they asked uh maybe we will
though right
the maybe is if they do we will salute
them on the podcast and say awesome
decision for you doing well if you were
if you were tony blinken or in a
national security advisor working for
the biden administration you just
hypothetically
what what would you recommend he does
differently or what do you what advice
would you
what council would you have access to
all the intel if i had access to all of
you based on you know if i had access to
all the intel and i got people around me
from both sides giving me feedback on
why to or why not to
then i would ask and say what so we got
a hundred years of reserve yes okay how
long do you think this crisis going to
last say 90 days okay 100 years 90 days
means we got 400 more years of reserves
why don't we go ahead and get 90 days
worth of supply right now lower the gas
prices by 25 35 40 percent and then 90
days later we can go back and see what
we can strike up a deal with somebody
else okay maybe you can put a timeline
on it that we're gonna
fix it for now but here's the other part
that i'll flip it on you is there's got
to be a long-term solution okay there
has to be a long-term solution these are
all nice band-aids you're putting on
there okay hold on reactionary oh
reactionary oh reactionary but what's
the long-term solution the long-term
solution is the one i'm i'm really
interested in because it's both ways to
go green
you know the eevee part nuclear you know
whether it's the nuclear the fossil
there's got to be
there's like for example california
yesterday newsom posted something on
twitter i'm like oh my god here he goes
again
he posted something on the uh on twitter
yesterday bragging about how great
california is doing i don't know if you
saw that or not
he said california raised the minimum
wage we increased paid sick leave
provided more paid family leave expanded
child care
you know
in this year will be the first state to
provide health care for all regardless
of immigration status that's the
california way did you see what i said
to him and then i i said i wouldn't brag
about it your policies caused
california's population to drop by 180 2
000 last year making it the first yearly
law since its founding in 1850s
bad policies have consequences right bad
policies have consequences
the the political system that we have
today the voting system adam it's so uh
reactionary that everybody is more
concerned about being re-elected that
you're not making good long-term policy
i mean you lived in california so you
have obviously strong opinions on this i
don't feel bad for californians
why they chose this
no no question about it they they they
they had the opportunity
to
cut off newsom and they overwhelmingly
by two-thirds i guarantee voted to keep
them i guarantee you in the comments
section right now 40 are saying you
don't that they don't speak on my behalf
well and let's not forget what
california did they perm uh permanently
enrolled or instilled mail-in balloting
they're allowing illegal immigrants to
vote they have a huge population of
sanctuary cities it's like the the the
yes that's still not gonna that's still
not gonna change the vote whatsoever
well i mean there's there could be some
disgrace
in the country arguably so
sanctuary cities are cute and all but
they're not swaying
millions and millions and millions of
voters well again there could be some
discrepancies in the actual voting
process if it was a you know
55 45 vote all right maybe
70 30 not so much
go back to the fact that we are
we're dealing with a population that
isn't educated well enough to understand
you know
if i vote for this
somebody has to pay for that
and how where where how does it all
balance out
and you know the stuff that newsom just
bragged about somebody has to pay for
that so your taxes will go up again
right
and uh you know i was recently in in la
what a dump
what a dumb lax's uh what to say that
that was a beautiful city man
there's homeless camps all over the
place and the city is drab and there's
just nothing that looks inviting anymore
yet there's still
people living there
but but my friends who have some means
they all live someplace outside of
the city
it's it's a shame and i i've been given
to understand that san francisco looks
pretty much the same these days san
francisco is worse than the lake the
prettiest city that ever was in the
united states san francisco yeah
now it's a
hot mess so so why don't they connect
the dots
did they just happen
just sporadically and there's nobody to
be held accountable for
where do you live i live in outside of
atlanta
atlanta yeah okay pretty good
atlanta yeah bad traffic though look at
that look at that real quick look at
that real quick
what's that that's l.a oh yeah
oh god that is la that's insane to think
that's la see i don't remember it
looking like that i lived there 20 plus
years
i remember looking like that that's what
they're doing is they're raiding the
trains when the trains come in from
amazon fedex the packages they
gangs of people go up rip the trains
open steal all the packages steal all
the goods and take off
yeah i mean that definitely inspires
people to say i'm going to wake up and
move to california tomorrow
i'm definitely on my way to go to
california tomorrow i just wonder how
long this is going to go because nothing
lasts forever you have to know that
winning doesn't last forever you're
eventually going to lose you know
the bulls you know dynasty six years
bomb lakers kobe shack poem you got you
know whatever
so nothing
it doesn't last forever i just wonder
what's going to happen to california
where some of them are going to wake up
and say you know what i'm done with this
final thoughts here before we wrap up we
got 10 minutes here
uh jack um
[Music]
putin okay with where he's at and what
he's up to
um
what what what level of optimism do you
have that all of this is going to get
worked out
uh versus
it all of a sudden getting even worse
and us and us being affected by this
i think i'm i'm more on the optimistic
side okay
um
assuming that putin isn't really going
crazy i mean really crazy crazy
uh because if
he has in the past shown
a realism that helped him
stay in power and
remain a player to be reckoned with
he cannot
if he if he goes too far
and and then we escalate and then
the worst thing might happen but
um
i i think this one
will be resolved not very quickly
but it will be resolved
if you could speculate what do you think
are putin's deepest deepest deepest
desires
to be recognized as the modern day
messiah
for the russians
like that yes
and what does that mean like how does
that play out the messiah
well
he's rebuilding the russian empire
is he though
wait because he's a he's about he's
about to that but that's his goal
so what's the next step after
after ukraine because this is obviously
an unmitigated disaster from a pr
standpoint and possibly from a political
standpoint
what's the next move because this is a
seems like a failed move attempt
moldova is a sitting duck and uh he
for moldova he has also a good reason to
attack because there is already in
a part of moldova which is not governed
by moldavians and the russians
lived there as an exclave i forgot what
it's called
and they could be asking for help
that's that's a that's moldova is weak
uh i don't believe he he will go to
the baltic states
and so what's his intention to
make ussr great again i mean is that
ultimately what he's looking to do he
wants the russian empire i don't think
he wants to rule the world
the russian empire
and
in the course of his lifetime he's
looking to do this he's 70 years old
let's say he lives to 90. you're saying
he wants to accomplish this in the next
two decades
you know as uh
patrick said you know you know we all
believe we're not gonna die right so he
still
looks at the future so do i
you're not planning for your death
unless you you're deathly ill right
so you know he's got plans
but ultimately he wants to rebuild the
gri and and what's the times frame that
he wants to bring it back to when russia
was this great superpower well
hopefully within his lifetime no meaning
what what does he look at and say
the 1960s that's where we were at our
peak what was peak russian empire in his
mind
oh it was the soviet union for sure
there were two superpowers the united
states and the soviet union
equal
particularly because of the the nuclear
uh tie you know
so
and he wants some of this back but
primarily he's he he's a he's a russian
more than
he he's not a communist anymore when he
says the the fall of the soviet union
when he said that was
the greatest uh tragedy of the 20th
century
he really really
deep down inside you know he meant you
know that russia wasn't strong anymore
because you look when you look at the
map the um
the the states the the republics of the
soviet union that are surrounding russia
now
um
they
provided half
at least half the strength of the
russian economy
the russian economy right now is what
number 11 in the world
gdp was right right
so there isn't much lesser two trillion
dollars what was it
it lit over two
so
he wants to build this back up in some
way
and he wants to do it by force by taking
over
nato countries or eastern bloc countries
in a clever way honey i believe he
thinks that he's been really clever in
ukraine because you know he's got
russians everywhere in other countries
living in other countries who could be
asking for help you know
look there's two things so go go to two
places say he succeeds with ukraine
there's 13 other nations that are
shivering
okay
if he succeeds with ukraine if he
succeeds with ukraine define success
meaning ukraine gives up and they say
hey
you know we're going to be more russian
then we're going to be part of you know
whatever may happen there like nato eu
if he succeeds ukrainian people will not
give up i agree that's why i say define
success oh i agree with you i don't i'm
just saying if he does if he does
succeed there the if is a very big if
it's not a small if it's a big big if if
he does but if he doesn't succeed
what does he do
does he re-strategize to
attack again five years from now ten
years from now or is he just going to
sit there and say guys i'm done with
that let's just try to be friendly with
the world again and let's not make
russia great you know
he's not he's not going to give up
because he's he's on a one-way street
you can't turn around
he can't
that would sort of deny everything that
he has become
and that he was and and belief that he
has in his own strengths
who do you think is his hero and who do
you think is his foil like meaning he
probably looks at boris yeltsin and
mikhail gorbachev as weak does he look
absolutely a stalin as the great
patriarch or lenin who who who would you
put in the
you know the hero column and in the zero
column i i'm not aware of any direct
statements of him you know
making a hero of some of his
predecessors
he has said some critical things about
lenin
i've forgotten i read something i forgot
exactly what it was so um
peter the great
pre-ussr times
as an individual imperial law no russia
no
peter the great put
russia on the map as far as europe was
concerned
before him
it was a real backward country with
95 of the population
farming the land
every once in a while you drop a really
good question
and it leads to a very good conversation
however we are coming to the end of the
podcast
jack appreciate you for coming out this
was a blast thank you mister
uh i believe we're back at it again
tomorrow with liz wheeler go ahead may i
put a plug in absolutely please podcast
yes
for sure imperative productions produced
a
audio drama based on my life
it's available on all
streaming uh platforms uh
audio platforms uh spotify apple and so
forth
it's really well made it's
professionally made in what which makes
uh it's called the agent
what makes
this better than the book that i wrote
it's because there's besides me there's
many other voices
so you uh it gives the story in added
dimensions stuff that i couldn't mention
in the book because it's
my voice
and there's narration as well so it puts
me into the context of history of the
world
that's the one i'm going to put the link
below for people to see that's awesome
thank you yeah we're going to put the
link below i uh
found the link i don't know if you did
find the link
uh we got the link in the chat and we'll
put it down below as well for people
fantastic fantastic folks go check it
out jack thank you so much for coming on
tomorrow we'll have liz wheeler and
there's going to be a surprise guest
there's a guest that we'll have on
friday morning that we probably won't go
live with but we're going to put that
only on spotify for people to find
spotify apple podcast stitcher
you might find that on youtube
they'll find out why that's the only way
we could do that one and then the other
one on friday afternoon you're not going
to want to miss it that's all i can tell
you right can't give you a name two
podcasts on friday tomorrow
but not on youtube only one of them will
be on youtube the other one's going to
be on spotify got it having said that
we'll see you guys tomorrow take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
you